في تطورات حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا وبعد
ساعات من اعلان اوكرانيا استعاده سيطرتها
على قريه اوروجينا في الجنوب الشرقي برزت
مستجدات لافته على جبهتين
وتعد بلده اوروجين الواقعه على اطراف اول
بلده تستعيدها من السابع والعشرين من شهر
يوليو اعلنت القوات الجويه الاوكرانيه
اسقاط طائر مروحيه روسيه كانت في اتجاه
باخمه صباح اليوم واخرى في هذه الاثناء
قال المتحدث باسم القوات الجويه
الاوكرانيه ان بلاده لن تتمكن من استلام
مقاتلات اف 16 من الحلفاء في فصلي الخريف
او الشتاء المقبلين مشددا على ضروره تعزيز
الدفاع الجوي بشكل فوري
اذا اخر تطورات على الارض على كل الجبهات
بكل تاكيد الاحاديث الان عن اورجينا حينما
نتحدث عن اورجينا نتحدث عن الجبهه
الجنوبيه من دونكو باتجاه يبدو ان الجانب
الروسي لحد الساعه لم يؤكد مساله السيطره
على هذه المدينه بل يتحدث على ان
المواجهات لا تزال حاسمه هناك ما بين
القوات الروسيه والقوات الاوكرانيه الحديث
هناك على ان هذه المواجهات لا تزال مستمره
وانه لم تحسم لحد الساعه لاي جهه ما صرح
بهذا الاداره الاقليميه فيزا هي من تقول
بان المواجهات لا تزال هناك بالاضافه الى
مواجهات حاسمه
باعتبار ان هذه المنطقه
يشكلان دعما لبعضهما القوات الاوكرانيه
كانت تحول بشكل او باخر السيطره على
اورجينا لتامين مواقعها
لكن الان الجانب الروسي يتحدث الاداره
الاقليميه تتحدث على ان هاته المنطقه لا
تزال تشهد مواجهات كبيره ما بين القوات
الروسيه والقوات الاوكرانيه غير بعيد عن
هذه المنطقه ودائما في الجبهه الجنوبيه اي
باتجاه الحديث الان عن رابطينه هاته
المنطقه التي لحد الساعه لم يتم الحسم
فيها الحديث على انها شهدت اليوم انزالا
كبيرا للقوات الاوكرانيه من اجل السيطره
عليها اخبار عسكريه قادمه من هناك تتحدث
على ان الفتره الصباحيه ما بين السادسه
صباحا والثامنه صباحا كانت هناك محاولات
اوكرانيه حديثه سواء عبر فرقه المشاه او
عبر الدبابات والمدفعيه في المحاوله
للاقتحام لكن القوات الروسيه تقول بانها
استطاعت بشكل ما ان تصد هذه الهجمات الان
في هذه الاثناء يبدو ان هذه الجبهه لحد
الساعه يبدو ان نوعا من الهدوء يسيطر
عليها وهذا يشير على انه ربما هي مرحله
استراحه من اجل القيام بمحاولات اخرى
المحاولات بكل تاكيد تقوم بها القوات
الاوكرانيه من اجل السيطره القوات الروسيه
في موقع صد الهجمات اذا هذه الجبهه اي
الجبهه الجنوبيه هي تشكل محور التحركات
الاوكرانيه من اجل كسب المزيد من المساحات
ودفع القوات الروسيه للتراجع الى الوراء
حتى تحكم القوات الاوكرانيه سيطرتها على
ربما قد تاخذها مدخلا باتجاه
الجنوب منذ زياده مساحتها لكن هذا الوضع
الذي نشاهده هنا قد يختلف تدريجيا بشكل
كبير جدا في الجبهه الشماليه والجبهه
الغربيه نتحدث عن التحرك الجيش الروسي
باتجاهي الحديث هنا العسكري على ان القوات
الروسيه لا تزال تتقدم في هاته الجبهه
وتستطيع واستطاعت ان تكسب المزيد من
المساحات مدعومه من تحركات القوات الروسيه
وهذا ما يدفعها لتاكيد تحركاتها كذلك
باتجاه لمن هاته الجبهه بالنسبه للقوات
الروسيه هي مهمه بمنحيين اثنين المنحه
الاول هو تطبيق الخناق على القوات
الاوكرانيه باتجاه لماذا لان هذه المنطقه
هي المنطقه التي تشكل منطلقا اساسيا
للضربات التي تتلقاها روسيا في على مستوى
الحدود سواء في كوبي او في كورس وكذلك
تتحدث القوات الروسيه على انها استطاعت ان
توقف تحرك او تسلل لمجموعه من القوات اذا
الهدف الاول هو سد هذه الثغره باتجاه
القوات الاوكرانيه ومن القوات الاوكرانيه
بالتقدم والنقطه الثانيه هي محاوله احكام
الطوق على ما تبقى من منطقه والالتفاف
باتجاه من اجل السيطره عليها وهذا يفتح
لها التحرك باتجاه مارينكا